eine Haltungsfrage das war für viele
auch der Umgang mit Corona und den
lockdowns der entscheidende rki-chef
spielte dabei eine große Rolle
regelmäßig hat er mit dem
Gesundheitsminister die Bevölkerung auf
harte Maßnahmen eingefroren gemahnt
gewarnt das Virus sei für uns alle eine
große Gefahr die Politik verhängte immer
härtere Maßnahmen darunter bundesweite
Schulschließungen Kinder wurden beim
Rodeln verfolgt wenn sie keine Maske
getrunken Kinder mussten zu Hause
isoliert werden verloren wichtige
Schulzeit und wichtige Zeit mit ihren
Freunden viele leiden bis heute schwer
darunter brauchen Therapien und jetzt
die große Kehrtwende lotharina sagt im
Interview mit der Zeit die Schulen
hätten offen bleiben können er schiebt
den Fehler jetzt auf die Politik sagt
aber auch er habe vor allem zu Beginn
der Pandemie nicht optimal kommuniziert
und er hätte mehr Gespräche führen
sollen nicht sie hatten sehr früh eine
kritische Position zu den Maßnahmen wenn
Sie das jetzt hören muss das
Konsequenzen haben ja ich würde mir
wünschen dass das auch vielleicht mal
Konsequenzen für den gesundheitsmin
hätte also natürlich erst die ersten
Schulschließungen kamen da war noch
Merkel in der Regierung gab aber
trotzdem danach war Lauterbach ja einer
der schlimmsten Scharfmacher und es
wurde immer den Leuten nur Angst gemacht
und die lockdowns wurden mit
fadenscheinigen Begründungen
durchgesetzt dann später 2G auch der
impfdruck in den Schulen auf die Kinder
die die Masken das ist ja alles aufrecht
erhalten worden und natürlich ist es
erfreulich wenn wenigstens mal einer
sagt wir haben da großen Mist gemacht
aber ich finde trotzdem das ist alles
noch voll völlig folgenlos geblieben
also mila ist jetzt weg Lauterbach ist
da die meisten die damals auch in den
Medien wirklich ganz übel gegen
Bevölkerungsgruppen die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollten oder die den
Lockdown kritisiert haben die die in
eine Ecke gestellt haben als
wissenschaftsfeinde als unsolidarisch
die sitzen alle in ihren Ämtern und die
sind alle völlig unbeschadet also ich
finde da muss tatsächlich auch mal eine
Aufarbeitung her der muss konkreten
Aufarbeitung hätte viele Familien haben
diese Zeit Herr Soest noch in ganz
bitterer Erinnerungen die Zeit für die
Kinder die zu Hause saßen aus sie sind
Vater wir haben sie diese Zeit erlebt
ich habe ja drei Kinder die sind jetzt
12 15 und 16 und es war schon wirklich
um es in meiner Sprache zu sagen echt
eine krasse Zeit weil du warst auf der
einen Seite ganz normal Vater Elternteil
du musst es dein Unternehmen oder
unseren Beruf mussten wir trotzdem
machen und gleichzeitig noch
Homeschooling und es war nicht einfach
was ich aber noch schwerwiegender oder
mindestens genauso schwerwiegend finde
ist dass die Kids nicht mehr in der Lage
waren sich zu bewegen wenn du zu Hause
bleiben musst ja nicht jeder kommt jetzt
auf die Idee zu Hause 10 Minuten bei
Fitness zu machen und das hat ja auch
seine Folgen ja es ist ja nicht nur so
dass wir mentale Herausforderung mit
unseren Kids heutzutage haben durch
diesen Lockdown der war sondern auch
sportliche auch physische und das finde
ich dass das jetzt mittlerweile so
weggewischt wird so lesen fährt dann
lass uns doch mal wieder nach vorne
schauen es ist ja nun mal so passiert
jetzt gucken wir gemeinsam nach vorne
wir können es eh nicht mehr ändern das
finde ich schon heftig und jetzt hören
wir heute an diesem Tag die
Schulschließungen die hätten gar nicht
sein müssen das sagt Lothar wieder wir
haben in alle vor Augen die ganze Zeit
haben wir ihn gesehen geht ihnen da
nicht auch die Hutschnur hoch wenn man
jetzt hört das hätte auch alles gar
nicht so sein müssen die Kinder hätten
weiterhin in die Schule gehen können ich
erinnere mich voran vor allem an eine
von mir hoffentlich richtig wieder gegen
gegebener Aussage als er damals sagte
das ist jetzt so das soll jetzt so sein
und das sollen jetzt einfach alle so
machen Punkt und jetzt stellen wir fest
dass er selbst eigentlich nicht wusste
was er macht dass viele Experten nicht
wussten was sie machen dass die
Politiker nicht wussten was sie machen
die die drunter gelitten haben war die
Bevölkerung und insbesondere die Kinder
und da jetzt so entspannt zu sagen gutes
war jetzt so jetzt gucken wir mal nach
vorne es geht ja auch weiter das finde
ich nicht gut wir haben hier schon
angesprochen Konsequenzen hat bloß
müssten folgen welche Konsequenzen
müssen das sein schreibt das nicht nach
dem Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag
ja definitiv sollte Konsequenzen haben
einen ethisches Handeln kann nur
moralisch korrekt sein wenn es eine
Verantwortung gibt wenn es eine
Verantwortungsträger gibt Verantwortung
bedeutet Rücktritt Verantwortung
bedeutet vielleicht noch was ganz
anderes vielleicht sogar eine
juristische Aufklärung warum nicht denn
wenn dich jemand hinstellt über Monate
über Jahre sagt diese Maßnahmen wie es
richtig gesagt dass Detlef diese
Maßnahmen dürfen nicht hinterfragt
werden auf keinen Fall hinterfragt
werden da fragt ich mich ähm was stimmt
mit diesem Menschen nicht denn man kann
sich entschuldigen ja aber eigentlich
kann man nur um Entschuldigung bitten
und wenn man das eben verwechselt oder
sagt nee das läuft einfach so weiter
dann ist es eigentlich nur ein hohes
Wort also mit der Entschuldigung ist es
nicht getan das ist konkret werden wer
muss gehen was muss genau passieren
bitte die ganze Regierung wenn man ganz
ehrlich ist über Monate über Jahre
hinweg sind falsche Informationen
verbreitet worden was Corona angeht
meiner Meinung nach und wenn man sich
dann hinstellt und sagt ja ein bisschen
Entschuldigung hier und dort ist das
viel zu wenig nein die müssen
zurücktreten ganz einfach
wirklich für die Kinder das Herz die
Folgen sind und das wussten viele Fach
Menschen schon vorher verheerend für die
Kinder Hersteller sie sind ein Mann der
Wirtschaft und die lockdowns hatten auch
wirtschaftliche gravierende Folgen was
genau sind die haben wir schwimmen wir
heute noch siehe Bildungssystem aber ich
glaube ich habe damals im Frühjahr 2021
bei einer anderen Tausch von Markus Lanz
von Staatsversagen gesprochen gute
heftig kritisiert aber mich ist schon so
es ist Staatsversagen es ist nicht nur
Versagen von einzelnen Politikern und
zwar Staatsversagen dahingehend dass wir
immer so tun als wären gut ich Corona
nicht gekommen aber wir haben eigentlich
nach der ersten Welle die Zeit nicht
genutzt worden ich habe damals
kritisiert wir hatten keine Tests wir
hatten kein Konzept die Altenheime zu
schützen und weil wir das alles versäumt
haben hat man dann eben die Kinder zu
Hause gelassen was natürlich irrsinnig
ist wenn die Schweiz schauen und andere
Länder wo sie nicht stattgefunden hat
und wenn wir dann noch schauen dass er
trotzdem Übersterblichkeit hatten wir
hatten deutlich Übersterblichkeit durch
die corona-krise und mal was sagen muss
okay der Staat hat im Prinzip das was
hätte machen sollen nicht gemacht z.B im
Schützen der alten und hat sich dann
sowohl Politik gehalten und für
sowas ähnliches machen aber für mich ist
halt wichtig bei so einer Tanten Aufgabe
war der deutsche Staat nicht
leistungsfähig und gleichzeitig haben
wir Politiker hat sich noch viel andere
Themen auf die kommen wir auch noch
vornehmen wollen transformationen der
Gesellschaft eine ökologisch und so
weiter wo ich aber sage wenn ihr das
schon nicht hinbekommen ich wollte sie
für größere Sache hinbekommen das heißt
wir brauchen eine komplettaufwertung im
Staat gesamthaft nicht nur in der
Politik aber vor allem auch in der
Verwaltung und wir müssen daraus lernen
darum müssen wir systematisch
aufbereiten müssen sagen was ist alles
schief gelaufen und wie können wir
zukünftig besser machen nur das findet
eben die Stadt sind auch bei anderen
Themen die Stadt der gerne über Panzer
reden als keine Panzer in Deutschland
fahren ist ein Dilemma sowieso was ist
passiert in Deutschland das Leid der
Kinder das kann man überhaupt nicht in
seinem Messen in wirtschaftlichen
Schaden aber
es gibt Studien die zeigen dass
verlorene Schuljahre verbundene
bildungsjahre
lebenslang geringere Einkommen bedeuten
das bedeutet im Prinzip Leute erreichen
geringsten qualifikationsniveause wenn
ihr Leben lang weniger verdienen nachdem
wir sowies diese wenig Kinder haben wenn
wir die oder schlechter ausbilden es
gibt ja auch die Studien die zeigen dass
die Grundschüler jetzt weit
zurückgefallen sind die werden ihr Leben
lang weniger zur Wirtschaft Beilage
tragen können das heißt aber auch sie
werden nicht in der Lage sein die Renten
zu erwirtschaften die wir gerne hätten
um die alten zu versorgen das heißt da
gibt es Folgekosten die sind gigantisch
und die wirtschaftliche Frage
aufzuwerfen weil sie zu corona-zeiten
sowieso wenn sie gesagt hätten wir geben
so viel Hunderte von Milliarden
volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden aus um so
diese Menschenleben zu retten das ist
moralisch geht das nicht verstehe ich
auch für Politikern der Lämmer nur am
Ende ist es so wir zahlen ein sehr hohen
Preis für das schlechte Corona
Management aber nicht nur dafür sondern
viele andere Dinge die bei uns nicht gut
laufen wie hoch ist der Preis kann man
so ein wirtschaftlichen Schaden nicht
nur gemünzt auf die Schuhe Schulen
sondern der Schaden der geblieben ist
durch die lockdowns in irgendeiner Art
und Weise es gibt ein paar hundert
Jahren sicherlich ein paar hundert
Milliarden ich meine es gibt ja auch
eine Studie aktuell Wirtschaft die sagen
allein durch den Corona durch keine
Kriege aber das Beispiel wenn wir dieses
Jahr alleine 175 Milliarden Euro
verlieren das sind 2000 Euro pro Kopf
und ich würde sagen durch Corona haben
wir ein vielfachen diese Schadens gehabt
normal Corona war eine externe Krise
aber wir hätten besser damit umgehen
können und das sollten wir Dauser etwas
lernen für die Zukunft darf ich einen
Satz dazu sagen ja gern wir sprechen ja
gerade auch über die Gelder die der
Staat ausgibt auch in Bezug auf die
corona-krise oder die Nachwirkungen und
es gibt Fördergelder für die Nachhilfe
von Kindern ja oder von Schülern aber
die zu zur Verfügung Stellung dieser
Fördergelder ist so schwierig und so
bürokratisch dass die Kinder oder auch
die Eltern gar nicht in den Genuss
dieser Fördergelder kommen weil die
Eltern irgendwann sagen okay ich muss so
viel ausfüllen dass so viel Bürokratie
dabei dann lasse ich das lieber und das
finde ich auch horent das kann doch
nicht sein dass wenn wir schon die
Situation haben dass unsere Kinder nicht
mehr genügend Bildung bekommen haben in
dieser Zeit das dann das Geld was zur
Verfügung gestellt wird um das
aufzuholen dann bürokratischen Problemen
untergeordnet ist
also es war gab es letztendlich Bildungs
Ministerin die so gesagt hat naja die
corona-lücke das können wir nicht mehr
aufholen das können wir nicht mehr
schließen da ist halt eine Lücke und
Pech gehabt so ungefähr und das finde
ich unglaublich ich meine wir sehen
jetzt wie schnell der deutsche Staat
wenn er denn will sogenannte
Sondervermögen schafft das sind
natürlich alle sonderschulden macht aber
ich meine über Nacht 100 Milliarden für
Rüstung man macht 200 Milliarden
erstmal waren es ja 100 Milliarden für
die Aufrüstung dann macht man 200
Milliarden jetzt dafür dass man eine
verfehlte Sanktionspolitik irgendwie
Ausgleich wir sind schon verwandelt
mittendrin in ihrem Zimmer da hat man
ganz viel Geld ich glaube man bräuchte
vielleicht 50 Milliarden oder vielleicht
sogar nur 20 um jetzt wirklich den
Kindern die gelitten haben die hier auch
noch schlechter gestellt wurden das sind
ja meistens auch die Kinder von ärmeren
Eltern wo die nicht mit Homeschooling
und so das ganze leisten können und
Medikation um denen ich meine da
bräuchte man gar keine riesen Summen da
braucht man nicht 100 Milliarden
wahrscheinlich aber dann bräuchte ein
gewisses Budget was man zur Verfügung
stellt hat man allen Ernstes jetzt sogar
noch mal bei den sprachkitas gekürzt das
heißt das ist dann auch für die Schulen
noch mal eine richtige Hypothek weil
natürlich in den ärmern Vierteln das ist
ja bekannt das Problem die Mehrheit der
Kinder spricht kein deutsch das heißt
statt Geld mehr zur Verfügung zu stellen
kürzt man Gelder und die Kinder werden
da ich finde das wirklich die Kinder
werden damit unglaublich gelassen sie
haben gerade schon ihr Thema touchiert
Frau Wagenknecht und deswegen gehen wir
jetzt in dieses Thema auch direkt rein
denn Demokratie bedeutet Debatte sehr
nicht hinterm Berg gehalten mit ihrer
Meinung zu den Panzerlieferungen und da
kam auch sofort eine Reaktion und zwar
vom früheren Botschafter der Ukraine der
hat heute getwittert und schreibt über
sie so eine widerliche Hexe Frau
wagenrecht trifft sie das persönlich
naja ich muss mal ehrlich sagen das ist
ein debattenniveau ich hoffe nicht dass
wir uns dem in Deutschland ernähren
sollten also dass ein Vize Außenminister
mit solchen Bandagen austeilt spricht
nicht für das Demokratie Format in
diesem Land aber zur Sache selber also
ich finde es ist ja jetzt entschieden
wir werden weil sie ihm auch was
entgegnen entschuldigen sie wollen sie
dann noch mal unterbreche
ja also ich finde Herr Melnik wirklich
macht auf eine unmögliche Weise Politik
und äußert sich Deutschland hat egal ob
man das jetzt gut findet oder nicht
inzwischen über 3 Milliarden Euro
bereitgestellt um der Ukraine
militärisch um die Ukraine militärische
unterstützen vor schon vor den
leopardenlieferungen wir haben über eine
Million Menschen aufgenommen die
flüchten was ja völlig richtig ist also
natürlich bin ich auch der Meinung wäre
vor einem Krieg flüchtet den sollten wir
helfen aber das sind trotzdem sehr viel
Mittel das sind sehr viel Gelder das
sind Wohnungen das ist ja ein etwas was
dann natürlich wiederum für andere nicht
da ist und wenn ein Land sich in solcher
Weise engagiert und dann die Vertreter
der ukrainischen Regierung und speziell
nichts anderes zu tun haben als ständig
deutsche Politiker zu beschimpfen ich
bin ja nicht die einzige also das ist ja
normal Herr Mütze nicht und andere also
alle die nicht seine Meinung teilen mit
denen hat er ja regelmäßig also die
beschimpfte auf unverhältliche Art und
Weise als ich finde eigentlich nicht
dass man sich das bieten lassen muss
also das persönlich
naja gut Hexe ist jetzt also es ist
natürlich irgendwie es heizt ein Klima
auf also ich meine wir sind jetzt nicht
in der Zeit wo die Diffamierung als Hexe
dazu führt dass man irgendwie verbrannt
wird das ist zum Glück Vergangenheit
aber es hat ja schon etwas also wenn man
das so was im Netzwerken in sozialen
Netzwerken da sind übel Beleidigungen
immer schon aber das soll man
offizieller Vertreter eine eines Landes
und das ist ja als Vize Außenminister
mit solchen verbal Orgien aufwartet ist
schon also für die für die
Debattenkultur ein echtes Problem und
unterirdisch also ich finde das einfach
wirklich nur widerlich muss ich dann
auch sagen